[Music]
what's up guys george campbell here
co-host of the ramsay show and we are
back with another episode of the best of
the ramsay show now these are some of
the most shocking calls we've taken on
the show from a woman who needs help
getting away from her abusive boyfriend
to a caller whose boss died and left her
a lot of money plus you'll hear from a
caller who had a bone to pick with dave
and had some choice words to describe
him enjoy
hi danielle how are you
hi mr randy thank you very much for
taking my call sure what's up
um
i'm in a position where i'm thinking
about selling my house
my son's father and i live together and
it's not the best situation
um
your blinds.com advice actually was
pretty spot on as far as our situation
goes
um i've connected with one of your elps
and i'm just really torn because i love
my home and i love my neighborhood but i
just want to be able to pay my debt off
and provide better for my son
okay so you own the home
with your boyfriend or
no sir it's just me
you own it
yeah
okay
um
when is he leaving
uh that's a great question
well i'll give you the answer
tonight
i can hear it no no i can hear it in
your voice
you sound really afraid to me
yeah well i'm trying to talk to you
outside and he's actually standing next
to me because she can't go inside
sir
um i have about 16 000 worth his worth
of debt um it includes a car a credit
card some medical debt from the birth of
our son
that
i get no helpless yeah um
my home
your elp said that i could potentially
walk away with about 88 000. yeah so i
could reasonably take all that off i
could
set my son up and myself up in a nice
townhome or a reasonable town home in a
nice area
good schools you have shot all this out
what is your income
uh
i just got a promotion at my job i've
been there about 10 years um i don't
quite know what it works out to be but
it's 21 an hour i believe it's like 44.
okay
how old are you
i'll be 32 this monster how old your
baby
[Music]
okay um
i don't know if you need to sell your
house or not
you may that's possible
but that's not your problem today is it
yes sir yeah
okay do you have family in the area
i do
um my mom passed away about two years
ago unfortunately so um
brothers and oh you have dad you have a
father and brothers in the area
yes i am my grandma my aunt who would
have room for me and charlie my son
okay um you need to get in the car and
go to your dad's house when you hang up
the phone
i can't do that i've tried that early
why can't you do that
do i need to call the police for you
no sir we've already gone through that
uh well i'm about to go through it again
where are you danielle are you outside
your house right now yes i am you are
okay do you have car keys where's
charlie where's your where's your son
and uh his father's home
in front of my car
all right you need to uh
when you hang up you need to call the
police you need to call your father
and you need to get you and your son
away from the sky do you hear me
do you understand
this is not going to work otherwise
honey
this is not a house problem and it's not
a debt problem
you and your son are in danger
do you understand me
hello
yes sir
i'm sorry
where'd you go
sir can you hear me yeah i can where are
you okay okay i'm sorry
did you hear what i said or were you
distracted yes i did so no i heard you
okay
so are you going to sit there
in the middle of the sewage or are you
going to fix it
i want to fix it that's why i want to
put my home and i just want to go no no
honey we don't need to call a realtor
we need to get the boyfriend out of the
house and that's going to involve the
police and or your father and your
brothers
he needs to leave it's your house
and you're afraid
you understand that this is wrong right
yes sir okay this is this is you're
you're not the crazy one
i'm talking to the same one you know
what a lot of times it feels like that
yeah i know
all right i'll tell you what we're going
to do
we're going to put you on hold and kelly
is going to make sure that law
enforcement gets over there okay no sir
don't you please no baby doll
i'm not going to be i'm i'm not
i love you and that baby
do what
i just needed to know if i should stop
my house or not
i'm sorry i'm sorry it's just okay
it's okay honey
you're you're
[Music]
you're in a horrible situation
and you have to make the moves to get
away from it
okay
and part of part of the type of
situation that you are in
is that his part of his psychological
job is he has convinced you that you're
not able to operate without him
and i'm convinced the only way you're
ever going to be able to operate is
without him
you understand me
yes sir okay
you listen you are worth
being okay
it's worth being okay for your kid it's
worth being okay
it's your freaking house
he's trespassing
we're gonna remove the trespasser
it has to happen okay you have to get
away from this guy
anyone who calls a national radio show
and is in this kind of distress
tells me that there's serious stuff
going on inside your walls
you understand and then once he's clear
we're going to put you with one of our
counselors
free i'm not going to charge you a dime
and we're going to walk with you and
then we can start making decisions about
your finances
but you don't have a financial problem
you need a boyfriend ectomy
[Laughter]
and it's happening today darling
it's happening today
do you understand
yes sir today
and danielle if you feel like you need
you and your son to be somewhere safe
then i would get out of the house as
well
removing him may not
well not you know but after he's gone
you can make this determination
you may need to go to local law
enforcement but you know get a
restraining order you can do whatever
you need to do at that point but you and
the baby need to get out of there until
he's gone and then you need to get
someone to remove him
and it's that simple
so
um
that's what you have to do and then you
can begin to have a conversation
uh in some form of sanity
because the situation you are in right
now is insane
it's an insane situation you're not
insane
but the situation's crazy girl
thank you sir thank you hey we love you
you hold on a second kelly's gonna pick
up okay and we're gonna make sure you
get taken care of
you weren't scheduled to be involved in
the show yesterday but you got involved
behind the scenes a little bit yeah
for those of you that were not around
yesterday for whatever reason i don't
usually tell you what yesterday is but
all that but this is the time we're
going to stop and do that
we had a young lady call in with rachel
and i on the air that um
became apparent during the call that she
was
a victim of domestic violence which i
don't even like saying that that way
because it sounds so antiseptic she was
a victim of her boyfriend beating the
crap out of her is a better way of
saying the truth
and uh we determined that and uh then
while we were on the call we determined
he was in the room that he had walked in
and was not happy and so um
it went from a financial question to a
question of her safety and her child's
safety and so forth on the air
live pretty wicked weird
and wild but um walk her through that a
little bit and um
john just happened to walk by the studio
and stepped in and uh i put her on hold
and he does a lot has done a lot of
uh trauma and uh crisis uh intervention
type counseling over the years and so um
trained in that but also experienced in
that so he got you got on the phone with
her and
we were able to get the uh the police
over there very quickly and uh the young
man is sitting where he should be now in
a cage
um which is where people like that
belong
and so i think they call that a jail but
i called it a cage um very simple either
one is very simple either one's fine
with me but they're both similar
situation here this is where this little
guy needs to be
and uh so that was pretty wild
discussion you were having in there off
air yeah i i noticed at one point i
didn't know who would who was in there
you know you kind of zone out and lock
try to lock
in in face to face you lock eyes but in
those situations you lock hearts with
somebody and then i noticed you'd come
in there after a while but yet it was
intense mainly because it was live it
was happening live and she was
not it wasn't philosophically unsafe she
was unsafe now and somebody else had her
kid and then you've got a mom who needs
to protect herself
but i'm not gonna leave my baby
unprotected and now you've got a messy
situation
and um
whenever i show up to something like
that i'm always looking at escalation
trends is this thing slowing down are
people separating and they just yelling
at each other or is it moving up and
this one moved up real rapidly
and um luckily that police department
there was super responsive and they
showed up and i'm grateful to them and
at the end of the day i mean we're
talking to a really brave brave young
woman brave new mom and um she's got a
hard row ahead of her but yeah things
got pretty dicey there for a minute yeah
and that's not that's not us
hollywoodizing this thing no it got
pretty pretty nice it was it was very
real yeah and uh he's a violent dude
and uh so
the uh
yeah of course so the end of the story
is she's safe her family's around her
and of course we're gonna uh we've
plugged her in with financial counseling
she does have some crisis financial
situation as well and she's got some
resources there some domestic violence
really was not even on the table for
discussion yesterday so but our our team
is rallying around her we're plugging
her in with counselors not of course no
charge and we're just going to walk with
her and make sure she gets
gets her life uh changed in a different
direction because it sure was going down
the toilet pretty fast there and we did
we we connected her some um
domestic violence resources there in
tampa too so that she can have a local
community that can be hands-on there
yeah and yeah so so she's safe and good
for those of you that were listening a
lot of you been
you know emailing us and worried and so
forth and uh so we thought we would give
you guys a bit of an update and you know
it's odd you and i were talking i think
it was last week on the air about this
correlation between um
extreme control over money issues and
domestic violence
that there's a correlation between that
because there's this
where where a husband or a boyfriend it
will not let you pick the cereal at the
grocery store you can't go grocery
shopping by yourself you can't buy
detergent you can't do anything without
his approval on every little nuanced
thing where there's that level of weird
toxic control over
a lady
a woman uh
with the money it's it's a high
statistical indicator that he's probably
hitting her
it's just about power right and i'll
take that power over i can get it yeah
it's about power and control and boy he
you know that was going on yesterday and
you could smell it in the air so i put
her on the air air it was um
it didn't take a genius to figure out
what was to you know to figure out what
i was dealing with what we're going into
there but you know i think the
the thing that um
you can't get away from
on the positive side
or the negative side of toxic toxic
behaviors
is that um
our behaviors is that personal finance
is 80 behavior it's only 20 head
knowledge so the chances of you being in
a relationship that are that
dysfunctional and being wealthy yeah
uh becoming wealthy in a dysfunctional
setting is just almost impossible right
because these things don't live in one
nice little compartment over here
uh and then not bleed over
or not not
bad bad metaphor but
don't don't reach over into the other
areas of your life so i mean you can't
be a punching bag in one area of your
life and then suddenly be prosperous and
healthy and
uh
winning at your career and winning at
your wealth building that kind of they
just don't it's not we can't
compartmentalize that tight right and
one of the challenges with relational
abuse of any kind is
you accept that as a given
you accept that as
well some days are good days
occasionally he'll come and in crying
saying he's sorry and it's going to be
okay
and so you start trying to solve that
inner chaos at the margins you start
trying to think of well maybe i can get
a better interest rate or maybe i should
trade my car in or it's probably my job
and your and you distance yourself from
this core nuclear reactor issue that is
hey you're not safe your baby's not safe
and this thing just escalates this way
right so um to anyone the decisions you
make on the money on the fringe is to
avoid the nuclear reactor at the center
are never good decisions they're not
because you're making them out of chaos
right well and you're making them uh to
uh
in order to mask that's right and in
order instead of dealing with with the
core issues and so you know larry
burkett used to say debt is not the
problem it's the symptom there you go
and so it's a symptom of a behavior
margie's with us in seattle hi margie
how are you
hi i'm good good how can i help
um we're on baby step two and
um
my husband got served with his summons
for a bad debt
um and so
after talking to some debt relief
attorneys
uh like four of them they suggested
bankruptcy
okay
and
we're
about 33
34 000
in debt and credit cards and we have
like a 11 000 loan on our car
and
about a hundred thousand dollars worth
of student loans combined
okay
and and what's your household income
um about 28 000
a year
okay who's not working
me
why
um
my daughter is at home
um
wick hold it and everything and
my anxiety
your daughter is how old
seven
and are you being treated for your
anxiety
yes
okay in what way
um therapy
[Music]
yeah okay
all right
well let me give you a couple of facts
that we can walk through
and then let's try to figure out how to
help you okay
okay
fact number one
student loans are not bankruptable
okay
yes so after bankruptcy you will still
have a hundred thousand dollars in
student loan debt
fact number two
your household income is twenty eight
thousand dollars
y'all are starving to death
and bankruptcy will not fix your income
problems
okay
so after bankruptcy
we get rid of credit card debt and by
the way you don't have a car anymore or
you still have a car payment one of the
two
if you don't give up the car you still
got the 11 000 in car so really when it
gets down to it if you're going to keep
the car and reaffirm it it's called in a
chapter 7 bankruptcy then you would have
thirty three thousand dollars in credit
card that is all you're bankrupting
yes and who served you
um
which credit card
um
um the credit card was credit one bank
okay and how much do you owe them
a thousand and six dollars okay
all right um
all right the third fact is that debt
relief attorneys
are generally not debt relief attorneys
generally what they are as bankruptcy
attorneys
and if you ask a bankruptcy attorney if
you're bankrupt that's like asking a dog
if it's hungry
yeah
so the advice you were getting from a
quote unquote professional was
self-serving advice on their part
so these are the things that are
disturbing me
and and you know so
we're getting advice from people that
are you know want you to file bankruptcy
because it's what they do you know
they're a hammer so everything's a nail
um
if you're gonna keep the car we're not
filing bankruptcy on very much and
really one thousand dollars is all
that's triggering this
and you have a household income of 28
000 which is less than half the annual
income of the typical household in
america
and so i'm not shaming you i'm just
saying you guys have an income issue
i've been there myself one year in my
life i made six thousand dollars okay so
i know how it feels it ain't no fun
what's your husband do for a living
um he works at a
car dealership
doing one supporter
um driving cars
driving cars 40 hours a week
um
well on average right now 33. yeah and
how old are you guys
in our 40s okay
all right
and so
for me to help you have a good life
a decade from now
i want to be able to paint a picture
that gets rid of not only the immediate
stress of this lawsuit
but also gets rid of a hundred thousand
dollars worth of student loan debt and
allows you all to have the freedom can
you imagine can you even for a second
wrap your brain around what it would
feel like in your home
if you guys made sixty thousand dollars
a year and had no debt
i can
i envisioned it now that's where i want
you to go
and that's where my mind takes me on
answering your question when you when i
start gathering the pieces of
information up
but there's a lot of things that are
going to have to happen for us to live
that dream together okay
and i i am not a mental health
professional and i do know that anxiety
is real and i am not
uh qualified to tell you when and if you
can go back to work or what you could do
but i am qualified to tell you that your
family needs income
and i am qualified to tell you 33 hours
a week is not enough to work when your
family's just broke your husband needs
to get six more jobs
especially since the one he has kind of
sucks
is that me a mean
no but i mean it's a step up from where
he was before so that's good
then he needs to take let's take two
more steps up
because he's in his 40s and when he's in
his 50s i don't want him making 28 000 a
year driving cars do you
no okay then we have to have to
intentionally take some steps up from
here
and part of that's cleaning off this
debt
who's got these degrees with a hundred
thousand dollars worth of debt
none of us
what did you study
um i did accounting
um
and i transferred schools so my credits
didn't transfer so i had to start all
over and
so that's
kind of
made it difficult at one point and what
was the last job that you had
um
[Music]
administrative assistant okay have you
ever done accounting in the vote as a
vocation
yes
okay
what did what did you do
um as an administrative assistant i did
um partial accounting you helped them
keep the books
yeah yeah good okay because you do know
how to do it you just didn't finish with
the degree
yeah good good okay
so there's a possibility you start doing
accounting for some small businesses in
the area
as you're working for yourself and doing
that from home where you can keep your
anxiety low
maybe
yeah i've been looking for work from
home okay um
is it the going out thing that gives you
anxiety what gives you anxiety
um well a ton of things but um
as for me getting a job it's more of the
like
i'm afraid of letting them down
uh like not being able to show up okay
i understand oh i see so if you had a
uh
an anxiety attack in the morning and
weren't able to go to work then you'd
feel bad about letting them down and
probably get fired eventually for doing
that right
yeah yeah okay
well that makes sense has that happened
before
um well it's happened where i haven't
been able to
um go out no no but did you lost your
job as a result
no
no my anxiety came after
after i stopped working oh after you
stopped working hmm yeah
that's interesting
okay
i don't know anything i mean dr john
deloney's not here to help me with this
so i'm kind of trying to channel my
inner doctor d here but the um
uh because i i know that what you're
facing is real i do know that and i'm
not questioning that but i'm trying to
figure out a way to get you guys some
income coming in up next is gonna be
chris in los angeles hi chris welcome to
the ramsay show
hey dave how are you doing great man
what's up
um there's a couple things one
you uh you've done some great work and
in some ways i love you
in other ways you're stupid and arrogant
okay
how can i help you all right by the way
that's a great way to start any
conversation right there
yeah well
my first question would be are you
smarter than warren buffett
how old are you
because you push i'm 35. okay cool
so what i'm sorry
let's stop just a second what's the
point of your call how can i help you
the the point of my call is you push
people into actively managed funds
when over time
if you push people into an index fund
they would have
about 50 percent more money when they
okay
um not sure where you went to school for
your math class
but you failed
um
the uh actually compounding cost i i
understand
dramatically i've been t i got socks
older than you i've been teaching this a
while okay
so uh
this is how this works now here's the
thing you're basically become doing what
bogel said and bogle invented a
wonderful thing with the index fund and
the s p 500 funds are wonderful index
funds are wonderful
they are not a cure-all and there is no
possible scenario unless you're an
absolute idiot in picking your actively
managed funds that you would have 50
percent more
in an index fund now the actual facts
are more than 50 of the funds
underperform the indexes
that is a true fact to your point that's
a different fact
the fact is two percent two percent
above in if you have a seven percent
return versus a nine percent return
which you have the compounding cost
bringing your return down by two percent
over 50 years
you'll have half the money do the math
on that google it that that would be
true too but none of those numbers
you're using are accurate in terms of
what the s p has produced or what
actively managed funds are produced the
actively managed funds that i personally
have picked have outperformed the
indexes by more than two percent as a
portfolio because it's fairly easy to
study mutual funds and pick them that
outperform but if you're not going to
study them and you're not going to have
a good advisor in your corner then using
the index funds is a great idea here's
what we actually found in the real world
versus um
versus someone's
hypothetical vacuum discussion of theory
okay
as we studied the largest study of
millionaires
90 percent of them
a large study of millionaires ever done
over 10 000 of them
90 percent of them became wealthy
without becoming without inheritance the
inheritance did not cause their wealth
and almost all and almost all of them
did it with their 401k with actively
managed funds
now some of the funds actually
underperformed the s p
and some of them over performed the s p
and some of them used an s p because
a good 500 fund was in there um what was
in their portfolio as well now let's go
back to warren buffett for just a second
are you aware that warren buffett does
not have all of his investments in index
funds
of course he hasn't been so in the
holding company i'm not sure other than
the fact that he has stated that the
average guy
because he's a vocalite the average guy
should buy index funds instead of
actively managed funds other than that
he doesn't actually do what he says he's
going to do with that he actually has an
actively managed portfolio called
berkshire hathaway are you aware of that
yes i am and he's doing it with with the
money he's leaving to his life when he
died well that's fine i mean where the
money's going's not not relevant to the
mathematical discussion the mathematical
discussion chris is simply this warren
buffett made comments frequently about
the average guy should buy index funds
and i really don't have a problem with
that you can get rich with index funds
not 50 percent richer that's complete bs
but you know that is true but if you but
you can get rich with index funds i
don't have any problem with that at all
if that makes me arrogant fine but i
think we're confused as to who's
arrogant on this call brother
i think that's the issue i've got a book
suggestion for chris it's called how to
win friends and influence people it's a
classic you should read it
no
i mean it's
good luck with it i hope it works out
for you but um
here's the thing
i've been doing what i've done doing for
30 years chris and it's made me a multi
multi multi multi-millionaire and i
invest in actively managed growth stock
mutual funds that outperform the indexes
across the four types we teach i
actually invest in what i tell people to
do
i don't tell people to do something
while i'm investing in something else
allen is with us alan is in new jersey
newark to be precise hi alan how are you
how you doing ramsay um just trying to
put this all together and i hope to see
how we can best unpack this
now i have about
me and my wife of about like 900 000 in
debt but it's not
all crazy that is investment debt so
just uh give you a run about um just
from what we make
uh my wife she's works at
the port she's a longshoreman and she
makes about 160. i work in the it field
and uh the veto field and i make about
115 so that's put that there
i have a nice little nest egg of about
60 grand
that's put aside and i'm 33 she's 32
we're married with four kids that's
under 10. so who is 10 another yeah so
that's one thing
um about the debt portion
i have about
166 000 in my primary home
i bought a house that i renovated and
you know i just renovated as a
two-family home
and that's
probably arv it's probably worth about
400 right now and i don't have no debt
on that but however i had to take it out
about a hundred thousand to put into the
property to renovate it right so so you
do have debt on it or you don't i don't
have that with that property no i don't
have that on it but but you got a
hundred thousand unsecured
unsecured that you used on that property
okay correct i got 20 and
well it's less than a hundred but it's
like a 20 in the line of credit yeah and
about you know 50 like about 50 from
your favorite place so far so
yeah i got i got that one and then we
bought another house a four family for
about four but for half a million but we
got it down to like 450 we put some
money into it we put about 40 into it
what's it worth today it's probably 650.
and what do you owe on that total
would i want it right now
450.
okay so i got it
okay there it is all right
and then
we have about
uh my wife's got a car
23 000 in car and about 6 000 on credit
cards no student loans we paid all that
off
and
yeah okay
why are you calling us how can we help
um now here's the thing the my
the property that doesn't have any debt
on it right
i need to pull money off that property
to get rid of the interest rate
on
the debt that i took out the re to
renovated right yeah why are you calling
us
to see what do you want to do
how could you what's the best way to
structure it and to see what your
recommendation is
okay
um
i started buying real estate when i was
22 by the time i was 26 own 4 million
dollars worth and i had a
about a 3 million debt on it
so i had a million dollars worth of
equity in the real estate
starting from nothing
um
what you're doing sounds very stressful
to me it does not sound like there's any
peace in your voice
yeah we try to figure it out we try to
structure everything so yeah i think you
i think you play the edges on everything
don't you
oh no not really you know
three or four times on the shell still
trying to hide it just in this
conversation
yeah you're man um
we're not in the debt restructuring
business we're in the debt payoff
business and it doesn't sound like
you're at a point where you want to
become completely debt free or that
you're willing to do what it takes to
get there yeah the the question you're
asking out and the the answers we're
going to give
are all around the same issue the issue
is okay you're 33 when you're 43 what
moves are going to make you the best off
okay the best off financially and have
the best quality of life with four
little kids and both of you working big
uh high stress jobs uh and everything so
i'm going to get rid of one of these
properties and a whole bunch of not if
not all of this debt
in the process
because i think that's going to add an
amazing amount of peace to your life a
you cut your
uh number of tenants in half
b you got rid of almost if not all of
your debt so 400 and 166 pays off
the hunt you get rid of everything but
the debt on the rental your you pay off
your mortgage your car your credit cards
and the hundred thousand it's owed and
you sell the 400 000 property that's
probably what i'm gonna do because that
will take me because the peace
and the calm steady movement rather than
the flailing about will cause you to
build more wealth over time
and you you've been you've been just
kind of pushing the edges on this maybe
you don't realize you are but it uh and
if you don't realize your art that's
even more of a problem cause i i know
this guy because i was him i mean i i
they
something about the real estate business
they take the risk meter out of your
heart and they put it on the table and
hit it with a hammer and break it so you
no longer can measure risk
and you don't you don't perceive that
all of this is risk you just see returns
you get let's just talk about the
renters are paying it off no they're not
the renters don't pay their bill half
the time you got a problem all the time
with that
and so
it's just an issue so no i um
you know i'm gonna move you backward
what feels like backward to you but set
you into a real calm place
let's visit where you are at that point
okay the probably the 650 with the 450
loan is cash flowing
it's probably cash flowing a little not
a lot
but you got zero debt then no house
payment
no car payment no hundred thousand
dollar unsecured hanging out there at a
high interest rate
and you only got a couple tenants
and you make 275 000 a year
and you're 33 years old that's a much
better place than where you are today
brother
to be that's a much more solid platform
to launch into the future
we don't find
alan very many people in our millionaire
study that borrowed their way into
becoming millionaires using the system
you're using or that i used when i went
broke
um
most people the vast majority of
millionaires do not do that to become
millionaires and so
that data is real
it's not a theory and it's not a well
what about the
there's no arguing with the actual data
most people dave especially young guys
they want to get into real estate
investing and our advice is to have a
paid for property for yourself first
then do all of your real estate
investing in cash
to them it sounds insane why do we say
that
because
the shortest distance to wealth is
always no debt
it's the shortest fastest route
and it's not just i made that up i mean
it's in the bible the borrower's slave
to the lender oh also all the data with
the 10 000 millionaires that we've
studied
oh also if you just walk around and talk
to rich people
they're not going to tell you you know i
did it with bitcoin
you know i did i got this big hit i
bought llamas
i opened a llama farm they were big one
time there was a big get rich quick
thing on llama llama farms wow and i
bought beanie babies they don't tell you
that and they don't say i did nothing
down real estate because i got to tell
you man i
i knew probably
100 people doing nothing down real
estate in the 80s
a hundred percent of them are out of the
business wow
or
they paid off everything and got out of
the debt business one of the two i
actually know one guy that he he cashed
out of about three quarters of his
portfolio ended up with 25 as many
properties and they were all debt-free
he got everything he got tired of he got
tired of living on the edge most people
go well that's stupid dave you're losing
out on all the cash flow of the
properties well the thing is in the in
when they're leveraged they don't cash
flow that much
you know that 450 over 650 he's not
making much money their margins on that
after you have after you have vacancy uh
you have loss
you know credit loss meaning they don't
pay the bill they go into bankruptcy you
have a heat and air unit go out you have
a roof leak
um you know you pay your taxes you pay
you know and by the time you finish all
that he's not making much cash flow on
that
he's not getting rich off that house now
the value may be shooting up but the
actual cash on cash there's not much
there
so this idea that somehow you're gonna
like
just buy a house and the money just
starts coming in no it really doesn't if
you leverage it up to your eyeballs so
it's all about delayed gratification
yeah it's go a little slower or go a lot
slower which in the end of the story
ends up being faster he who hastens to
be rich will not go unpunished cory is
in little rock hi corey welcome to the
ramsay show what's up
hi dave how are you better than i
deserve how can we help
my name is corey
i'm 32
and
i
my boss just passed away a couple of
weeks ago
and so he left me
some money
and so i'm just trying to really figure
out what i'm supposed to do like my dad
has told me what i need to do but it's
just it's a lot going on and i'm just
trying to because i don't have a job now
since my boss passed away but
boss left you money in his will
yes
wow that's an unusual arrangement
i was his personal assistant for eight
years
okay
yeah so he he did um
he was an oil contractor and so i did
all his
scheduling everything i was
as he used to call me his go-to go-to
gal
all the time so i mean i just kept up
with all his books and everything that
he needed done
and so after i knew he didn't have he
didn't have family then
he did he did
okay so his wife is the one that
actually
called me and let me know that i was
left something
oh okay so he didn't leave everything to
you no no no no no no
i'm just trying it's just an unusual
story it's a wonderful story but i'm
trying to understand so the uh how much
did he leave you
1.25
million dollars
yes
wow
oh my god
i couldn't vote i couldn't believe what
i mean what was the old guy worth a
billion or something
uh he he he he has a lot i mean several
properties i've
helped him
manage his properties
he would take me on trips with him and
his family my kids he took care of my
kids i mean wow he was an amazing person
wow so are you married
no okay how old are you kiddos
i have a 15 year old a four-year-old a
three-year-old and 11 month old what was
your income before before you lost your
job
i was making 65 okay 65 000 a year
1.25 million
wow and i was pretty much living
paycheck to paycheck doing that i mean i
shouldn't have but
i mean my kids are
i'm doing it on my own so yeah so do you
have any debt currently any consumer
data
yes i have um student loans and i have
about forty thousand dollars in student
loans
um we're renting an apartment so
just month by month that's twelve
hundred dollars for our rent
and then my car my mom gave me
um her car so i have a 2006 honda
odyssey
museum all right well you're very wise
you sound a little bit overwhelmed by
this a little bit scared
my dad suggested
that i because my boss was very flexible
with my
went because he knew i had kids and
everything so it was a lot of i could
work from home doing calls calls and
everything like that i could do a lot of
stuff from home
but now
i don't think if i get another job i
will have that and it's kind of a
viewpoint my dad was looking at so he
was thinking like maybe if i take a
break until my youngest who's 11 month
old starts kindergarten
because right now it would be like
daycare for all of them well minus my 15
year old it would be daycare for all of
them and
he doesn't think that it would be wise
for me to go back to work just yet and
just
use the money
i don't i don't i don't know okay all
right well what what i would suggest you
do is that you build a
um
let me kind of pan back let's just zoom
back for a second from worrying about
uh
what we're doing tomorrow
overall
someone just handed you 1.25 million
dollars to manage
that's your new job
and you don't know how to do it
okay is that right
yes that's why you call me
yeah and that doesn't make you bad it
doesn't make you bad it's just that
you've never managed 1.2 million dollars
before right
no
definitely not so what you do when you
have a a responsibility that large
which is what this is it's not a woohoo
i hit the lottery moment and i don't
hear that in your voice by the way i
hear a little bit of fear a little bit
of grief still from your friend passing
away a little bit of shock and awe which
i have in my voice that you got this
much money from your employer that's
pretty cool um
and uh so
here's what i suggest that people do
you need to a
number one
move
slowly
okay
if you feel urgency or someone pushing
you
stop
okay
because where may people make mistakes
when they don't know what they're doing
is they go too fast let's pretend you're
driving a car for the very first time
i took my kid out in the church parking
lot with the jeep and the straight shift
to teach him how to do the strike drive
and to do the straight shift the first
rule is don't even change gears let's
just figure out and move
slowly get in trouble stop
all right and that's what you're going
to do here because it's something you've
never done before
okay
second rule is the bible says in the
multitude of counsel there is safety
so i want you to build your own advisory
group your own board of directors
not to tell you what to do
but to advise you and teach you and then
you decide what to do
okay you got a pencil
yes
okay
first thing you need is you need an
investment advisor
click smart investor at
ramseysolutions.com you can find one
that we suggest
the second thing you need is a tax
advisor click tax elp ramsey solutions
dot com and find one that you like
the third thing that you need
is sometime in the next year i suspect
you're probably going to buy a home and
pay cash for it an inexpensive home
under two hundred thousand dollars
okay and you're going to need a good
real estate agent
that's your third person on your board
on your advisory board again we've got
elps that can sit down with you and help
you with that
you need to make sure you have the right
kinds of insurance in place
so you need an insurance health
insurance anymore there you go you need
insurance in place and you again we've
got elps to help you with insurance
we're not in any of these businesses but
we've got people set up to where you can
form your advisory board and their goal
is not to tell you what to do and your
goal is not to hire a babysitter
you're a grown woman so your goal is to
gather information from advisors and by
which you go slow enough that you learn
and then you make the decisions
okay
and i think you can buy a home for cash
and invest some of this and not have to
go back to work
okay but i can do like my dad said yep
but it's not it's not by using the money
it's by investing the money and using
the money that the investment creates
okay we're not going to use any of the
money
we're going to put it in an investment
and it throws off an income for you to
live on
okay with your investment advisor and
you're going to not need a lot of income
because your house is going to be paid
for and your car is going to be paid for
you're not going to have any debt and
you're going to be on a budget
okay because like i said i was paycheck
to paycheck you're not going to live
paycheck to paycheck anymore you're just
going to tell every dollar what it's
going to do that's coming in you're
going to have more dollars than you used
to have
okay and i want you to go through ramsey
plus go through financial peace
university and learn how to handle money
i'm going to pay for that we're going to
give it to you for a year
because you've got to get up on top of
this thing or you're going to live with
this horrible taste on the back of your
tongue called regret
move slowly and learn and put advisors
in your corner
okay if you enjoyed this episode click
here to watch the next one where you'll
hear some of the most unbelievable
marriage fights